Well,
we had been on the same page on
immigration reform.
Our Democratic Caucus has adopted
certain principles that relate to
securing our borders and enforcing our
laws,
protecting our workers,
unifying families,
and having a path to legalization.
And they were the principles that we had
been arguing from debating from,
uh,
for several years now.
So I would hope that any comprehensive
immigration reform that we would have a
would contain those principles.
We also recognize that immigration is
essential to our competitiveness.
We need all the fresh,
wonderful thinking from all over the
world to be part of our economy.
And we also need many of the young
people who have been educated in our
institutions of higher learning,
especially in the sciences to stay here.
So a short of a comprehensive
immigration reform at or part of it.
We'd like to see a green card stapled to
every,
a graduate degree.
In that regard.
I appreciate the question because I have
said to the president and to my
colleagues and to all who will listen is
that we will not be in a position to
have the comprehensive immigration
reform that we want unless we enlarge
the issue.
Many people are concerned in our country
is that their job security and they
think they're losing their job because
of trade or because of immigration.
So until we have progressive economic
agenda creating good paying jobs in
America,
people have more sense of security
themselves.
Uh,
we won't be able to have the immigration
reform that is necessary and worthy of
the subject that we are addressing.
So I,
I believe the foundation has to be laid
by a strong economic job producing job,
creating business,
creating a agenda for America.
And then we can go to the next step.